Let's do one more. Have you ever left your house with your umbrella thinking
it's going to rain but then it doesn't? And then you just end up carrying your
umbrella around all day? Let's say that the null hypothesis is that it's not
going to rain and the alternative hypothesis is that it will rain. Now we're
going to do kind of the opposite from what we did the last quiz. This time,
decide which of these correspond to rejecting the null or retaining the null.
Or, if the null true or the null is false.. Write A, B, C, or D in each of
these boxes. Just to clarify a little more, if the null is true, which of
these, A, B, C, or D, corresponds to that. If we decided to retain each H
naught, in other words we decided that it's not going to rain, which one of
these, A, B, C, or D, should go in this box?